[Music]
one of the most frustrating things about
firestore is modeling your data as a
hierarchy of subcollections because even
though this is a very intuitive data
model that represents relationships very
well it's not very practical because you
can't join these collections together to
query them at the same time well at
least that was the case until now
firebase just recently released a new
feature called collection group queries
in today's video you'll learn how this
new feature makes working with
subcollections a lot more intuitive and
we'll put this new feature to use to
make a deeply nested threaded comments
feature with angular if you're new here
like and subscribe and you can grab the
full source code from fire ship IO and
if you're building a product with fire
store consider becoming a pro member to
get access to the data modeling course
let's first take a look at the problem
that we can now solve with a collection
group query let's consider the very
typical data model of blog post comments
users can have many comments post
connect many comments and a comment
belongs to a post and a user will have
at least two screens in the app that we
want to fill with data most commonly
we'll want to show all of the comments
associated to a given post but we might
also have something like a user activity
feed that queries all the most recent
comments from that user read it would be
a perfect example of this and reddit
also allows users to respond to comments
so you can get these deeply nested
threads of comments which is another
problem that is much easier to solve
with collection group queries now if
you've been using firestore for a while
the most likely way that you modeled a
relationship like this was to create a
root collection of comments and then
save a post ID as well as a user ID on
each individual comment the reason you
wouldn't make comments a sub collection
of a post is because you then wouldn't
be able to query all of the comments
created by an individual user and that's
the exact problem that collection group
solves because it allows you to group
all the collections in the database
based on a shared name or ID and it
doesn't matter how deeply nested these
collections are they can be nested up to
a hundred levels deep and still be
included in a collection group query and
that's extremely useful when you have a
complex hierarchy of data like you would
with reddit comments in this example
here we have a collection of posts and
then you can see an individual demo post
has a sub collection of comments the
comment document itself has a user ID
and the comment text now in order to
create a reddit style hierarchy we can
also give each individual comment its
own sub collection of calm
the only important part for the query is
that the subcollection shares the same
name and we can just continue to follow
this pattern until we hit fire stores
limit of 100 nested sub collections so
this data model preserves the hierarchy
of comments and replies but now let's
take a look at how we can group these
collections together to query them based
on the user ID and also some of the
caveats that you'll run into along the
way first let's take a look at some
vanilla JavaScript using the firebase
SDK version 6.0 or greater to join all
of these sub collections together we
just called database collection group
with the name of the collections which
in this case is comments that's going to
find all of the comments collections
throughout the entire database and join
them together and then we can make
queries across them just like we would
with a normal collection for example we
can call where the user equals a certain
user ID to filter just by that user or
we might want to order by a created at
timestamp but if you try to actually run
this query in your own code the first
thing you'll see is this firebase error
missing or insufficient permissions
that's because there are some special
rules in place for collection group
queries first of all at the very top of
my rules you'll notice that I'm enabling
the rules version two in this example we
just want to go ahead and make all the
comments readable and writeable so we'll
say path equals star star slash comments
and that will allow access to any
document in a comment sub collection but
in a real app you would most likely lock
down write access for the logged in user
with a matching user ID so that's going
to take care of the permission error but
now we're going to see an error that
says that we need an index for this
query that will also give you a link
directly to the firebase console to
create the index so go ahead and click
on that unlike a regular collection
query you'll need an index for every
collection group that is filtered by a
certain property that'll take a minute
or two to set up but once it's done you
should be able to make this query
successfully now that you know how
collection group queries work I want to
show you how you can actually make use
of these deeply nested data structures
in a real-world JavaScript application
will be using angular and at the time of
this video you'll need to install
angular fire using the next tag and what
we're building is just the front-end
application that can query the data that
I showed you earlier in the data model
first we query the top level sub
collection associated with the post then
from there the user can lazily load
additional comments or replies to an
individual comment by clicking this more
button
and another nice thing about this data
model is that we can query the data very
efficiently and as we'll see we can do
so in a way that doesn't require any
complex query code and will also create
a second view that uses the collection
group query to flatten all of this data
out for a single user the first thing
we'll do is go into this post component
which is responsible for displaying the
post itself as well as the sub
collection of comments nested under it
now to get the first level of comments
that are nested under a post all we have
to do is make a reference to that sub
collection in the database and then
we'll make sure to call snapshot changes
here as opposed to value changes and the
reason we call snapshot changes here is
because it contains additional data
about the document itself like the ID
but more importantly the full path to
the document in the database now in the
component HTML we can go ahead and loop
over that observable of snapshots and
then we'll pass each individual snapshot
into this app comic component which will
create in the next step setting up an ng
for loop with the async pipe will
automatically subscribe to that
observable to retrieve the items from
the database and then we'll handle all
the presentation logic in this child
comment component in the comic component
the first thing we'll do is set up the
input property so we can pass the
document snapshot from the parent to the
child the query document snapshot
contains all the data from that document
in the database but it also contains the
document ID and the full path to that
document in the database but each
individual comment might also contain
its own sub collection of comments which
will go ahead and call replies here as
the property on this component now we
can come down here to ng on an it to
define all these properties the idea and
the data just live directly on the
document snapshot we can get the full
path to the document as a string by
calling comment ref path we need this
full path to make a reference to the
subcollection
we can make that reference by calling
database collection then passing in the
path and appending comments to the end
of it that'll give us a reference to the
sub collection of comments nested under
this particular comment and we can use
snapshot changes to get the actual data
snapshots as an observable now the last
thing I'll do is add a method down here
that allows the user to flip the show
property to true and that will be fired
when the user clicks the show replies
button in the template I'm going to go
ahead and show the full path to the
document in the database as well as the
actual text of the comment then I'm
going to set up a div here with ng if so
this will not be rendered
unless that show property is true and
then inside that div I'm going to add
the app comment template which is the
same template that we're defining right
now so we're calling it recursively and
this works really well because the
observable won't be created or subscribe
to until the show property equals true
so that gives us a very easy way to lazy
load data on a deeply nested thread now
if you wanted to traverse the entire
tree of comments by default all you'd
have to do is set the show property to
true and it would fetch every single
comment nested under the starting point
and that's all it takes to access deeply
nested data like this so using a
recursive pattern like that can be very
powerful and very simple at the same
time and the great thing about a
collection group query is that it's now
practical to do this because we can also
make additional queries across this data
without having to worry about it being
deeply nested and that actually becomes
the easiest part of all because all we
have to do now is go into our user
comments component and we call a
database collection group point to the
comments collection name and then just
call snapshot changes with whatever
query logic that we want to apply there
and that will give us all the comments
for that user but without the hierarchy
structure so we get them flattened out
and just a regular array that we can
loop over over all the collection group
query is a very simple feature but one
that adds a ton of flexibility to data
modeling and fired store I wouldn't
recommend going and restructuring your
existing database but it is definitely a
feature you should consider going
forward I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there if this video helped you
please like and subscribe and consider
becoming a pro member at fire ship IO
you'll get access to the full fire store
data modeling course as well as a bunch
of other exclusive content thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]